hello everyone and welcome to one of the
most important tournaments of the year
it is ala's race to the candidates
tournament and he's trying to defeat
three grand Masters over a set of two
games so six games in total he has to
win all six in order to overtake um
Wesley so and qualify via the the rating
criteria for the candidates tournament
well Anish is waiting to see what gkes
will do in the chenai grand Masters will
he overtake him in the FES circuit and
um while I'm recording this this is the
third game ala played the fourth game is
already being played but we're going to
discuss that after we check out this one
as there is quite a lot to enjoy here so
let's check it out ala opened with E4 we
have Pawn to C5 by Andre shakach shakach
sorry French grandmas we have Knight to
F3 E6 the French variation obviously and
now D4 ala goes for the open Sicilian
and this is now with E6 known as the
Caris variation of the uh of the uh
Sicilian uh A6 and now Bishop to D3
transposing into the con variation and
now Knight to F6 and Bishop to C5 are
the two most played moves here but here
we have Pawn to D5 it is the 10th most
popular continuation obviously he
prepared a very nasty surprise for alira
so let's see it e captures on D5 Queen
captures on D5 now putting pressure on
the G2 pawn and alza offers it he plays
Knight to C3 of course he offers the
Knight but you cannot take the Knight if
you take the Knight and just Bishop B5
check of course hangs the queen here so
Queen captures on G2 was played and now
Bishop to E4 ala offers a pawn for some
counterplay along the G file and he will
uh develop the pieces um and Castle
Queen side of course we have Queen to H3
and now Queen to E2 Knight to F6 and now
Bishop to F3 uh not of course interested
in giving up the knight uh the bishop
for Knight and there is a game where
Knight beat D7 was played it was played
in
2001 between aaor and David Beres and
the game ended in a draw and then the
the Knight the Knight B to D7 is
actually one of the top moves
recommended by the engine but here we
have Bishop to C5 also one of the top
moves recommended by the engine and it
is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how ala
deals with this he of course moves the
Knight Knight B3 attacks the bishop and
Bishop back to E7 uh Bishop to F4 nicely
preparing the castle Queen side while
the Bishops are attacking Black's Queen
side castles and now a queenside castles
we have Pawn to E5 offering a pawn uh
for some counterplay and it is in fact a
very good move uh Bishop captures and
Knight to C6 but now ala just gives up
the light score Bishop Bishop captures B
captures and The Rook H to G1 uh if you
can get something like Rook G3 Rook D to
G1 and then put pressure along the G
file your position will be excellent so
G6 of course um Andre will not just wait
for that and now Rook to D3 this is how
ala goes about it uh Queen to H6 with
check and now Pawn to F4 we have Bishop
to F5 attacking the rook and Rook D to
G3 uh we have Pawn to C5 uh and now Rook
to G5 not just uh uh blocking the queen
but also threatening Rook captures an F5
as there's a pin along the G file so
here Bishop back to E6 and uh
interestingly Al's position is
completely winning here uh but it's not
uh it's not uh that clear why so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the absolute best move for ala while I
give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Knight to
E4 uh interestingly ala did not play it
seems to be uh a very complicated idea
uh point is that you just want to
capture the Knight and the problem with
Knight captures on e4 is Rook to H5 and
that just wins the queen there's no way
out of this so uh you cannot play that
what you would have to do is play
something like Queen to G7 but then you
uh I mean you you voluntarily go into
this pin and then something like Knight
B captures and C5 and Black's Position
will just um disappear of course this is
impossible as the Knight here will not
be defended so you're going to have to
play something like Rook F to C8 now ala
could capture and after F captures you
just push H4 there's no stopping H5 uh
there there's nothing black can do here
like try Rook A8 you try to give up the
exchange white will just ignore you and
if you move the king then H captures and
G six you have to stop the attack
somehow but still after The Rook moves
it's a it's a dead loss position for
black uh but it is quite a lot of moves
so ala decided to go the other way
around he played Knight to A5 first he
wants to go Knight to C6 and now we have
Rook F to C8 sort of stopping that and
now Knight E4 still works the nothing
changed really here ala goes King to B1
and now we have King to f8 unpinning
from the G file and now the Knight to E4
idea no longer is an option so goes
Knight to C4 and now Knight to D7 Andre
defends properly and now he sort of
Wiggles out uh Bishop to D6 and uh sorry
Bishop to D6 by Ala and now Rook to E8
just defending that Bishop ala trades
Bishop captures Rook captures and now
Queen to F3 attacking that Rook uh so
Rook to B8 and now Knight to A5 going
for the fork here with Knight to C6 and
interestingly here Rook e to E8 was
played avoiding the fork alza played
Knight to C6 and he was in this position
un move 28 that Andre shakach shakach
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here he was very low on
time uh when he resigned as I understand
that he had 40 seconds on the clock some
some people say he even had 10 seconds
on the clock uh If you defend properly
here this is a draw this position is a
draw if you allow the engines to play it
out but of course every pretty much
every position is a draw if you allow
the engines to play it out uh probably
he resigned because he thought that uh
uh that his position was just so bad and
Al's position was just so overwhelming
uh but to give you an example okay you
just move the Rook let's say Rook be to
C8 and there's not a clear way for white
to continue here like you go Knight to
E5 uh black will happily trade and after
captures captures okay you've opened up
the position a little bit but there
there's not much you can do here like
Rook C to d8 what do you play here you
can't go like something like Knight E4
because Bishop to D5 stops the Knight
and and if you try something like Queen
F6 to put some pressure here uh just
Queen to G7 so it's not a problem like
Queen F2 and now all of a sudden it's
black who's um creating some maybe
threats of his own so what you would
what you could do after this Knight to
C6 move uh maybe try something else but
what else is there to try like like we
said Rook bc8 you can't Advance the pawn
to H4 because the queen covers that and
you cannot give up the H Pawn if you had
a way of playing H4 H5 then it's fine
but you just don't and you don't have
time to prepare it you don't don't have
something like Rook G3 because the the
pawn just disappears from the board and
other than something like Knight E5 or
Knight A5 there's just no better
continuation but uh obviously Andre saw
something that uh uh well still uh is
still to be seen and maybe we'll we'll
get a better idea of what that something
is once someone interviews him uh but as
I'm recording this game they are already
playing their second game so we'll see
what happened in happens in that one but
for now ala is in three out of three and
he needs three more to overtake um
Wesley so and qualify for the FED
candidat tournament uh via the rating
spot I checked out the position before I
started recording the video seems like
Andre has a very nice setup very nice
attack going on uh maybe not an attack
but maybe a potential for an attack it's
a really wild position Anish gear even
tweeted that it's sort of like a dream
Kasparov position where you could just
attack so we'll see what happens as soon
as it's finished I will inform you guys
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Gregory
Novak Kenneth Fu John dugdale Ian
Sterling and Nicola V for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day